20th so let's get to the numbers shall
we the high for the day today
59 degrees now keep in mind yesterday
it was 80 degrees that's how much of a
temperature drop we had all right and
our normal is 76
nearly 20 degrees colder than normal 41
overnight low like we talked about
that was a chilly temperature that we
have not seen since late february
49 outside right now as we leave here
our news now studios we're going to put
our jackets on it is cold out there
14 for our wind speed so a little breezy
at times you can see our
tower cam moving there a little bit 44
in henderson north las vegas 47
other neighborhoods though north though
those winds have started to calm down a
little bit
less than 10. now there are freeze
warnings just not in las vegas
trump mesquite those of you down in
south county yes you
have freeze warnings that go into effect
at 1 am and last until 8 am as
temperatures will drop below freezing
fire weather warnings still red flag
warnings continue for the
lake down river to laughlin that remains
in effect through tuesday
at 3 p.m coming up we'll talk about how
cold it will get overnight
and how long that will last all in your
most accurate forecasting
all right ted we'll see in a few minutes
a terrible tragedy in the southeast
valley
after police say a man throws a
two-month-old baby off a balcony
killing her it happened early saturday
morning at an apartment complex near
saint rose parkway and eastern
and tonight we're learning more about
exactly what happened
eight news now reporter or mana joining
us now live in the newsroom with
the rather disturbing details orko well
denise
this arrest report lays out the chilling
events from saturday morning's homicide
a man ripping his fiance's baby from her
arms
and throwing the infant from their
second story apartment
i spoke to a neighbor who says this is
nothing short of shocking
the most bizarre thing obi canoe still
can't believe the horrifying event that
took place saturday morning in the
apartment unit right above him a charred
balcony and broken windows are all that
remain from what can only be described
as a terrible tragedy
metro police say this man 32-year-old
clarence martin jr threw his fiancee's
two-month-old baby girl from their
balcony
killing her the clark county coroner
identifying her monday as london martin
canoe witnessing the aftermath
the mother of the slain child she was
already out here she was very hysterical
about everything that had been going on
police also say martin set the apartment
on fire killing the family dog canoe
tells me he has to move out because of
the damage
when i come out the house is in full
blaze that's nothing compared to
whatever
the family of the baby is going through
it's just an awful
thing that happened martin drove away
causing two car accidents on his way to
mccarran airport according to an arrest
report he crawled onto the baggage
conveyor belt that led to a secure area
employees called police and martin was
eventually arrested the arrest report
also
says martin had prior mental health
issues and hadn't eaten or slept in the
last three days
i just don't think that somebody would
that can do that was in their right
state of mind
but canoe says nothing justifies what
happened my deepest condolences to the
family
martin is now facing open murder arson
and animal cruelty charges
he's due in court tomorrow live in the
newsroom tonight orca manna 8 news now